يتضمن المشروع السعودي البريطاني وضع
الواح شمسيه في مدار الارض يتم تجميعها
بواسطه الروبوتات يتم تحويل الكهرباء الى
موجات راديو عاليه التردد تنتقل الى سطح
الكره الارضيه
وبالعوده الى الارض فان هوائيا شبيها
بالشبكه يبلغ عرضها عده اميال ومربوط بين
القطبين سيقوم بتحويل الموجات الراديويه
القادمه من الفضاء الى كهرباء ويتغلب وضع
الالواح الشمسيه على قمر صناعي على
المشكله التي تواجهها الالواح الشمسيه على
الارض الفيوم كلها هذه الالوان التقاط
اشعه الشمس على مدار 24 ساعه لما يعمل على
توفير مصدر مستمر للطاقه في جميع ظروف
الجويه تم تخصيص اربعه فاصل ثلاثه مليون
دولار امريكي في الوقت الراهن لتطوير
المشروع الا ان التكلفه الاجماليه للمشروع
ستكون اكثر بكثير وستصل الى عشرات
المليارات وفقا لدراسه الجدول الخاصه بهذا
المشروع والتي قدرت انه يمكن ان يكتمل
بحلول عام